hey guys it's justine and i'm here with
jenna and today i thought we would do a
really fun video
i think it's gonna be fun that's gonna
be great time we're doing a blindfold
tech test not a taste test well anyway i
guess i can taste it
it could help jenna is going to go find
some things in my tech closet
and i'm going to put my blindfold on and
i'm going to try to figure out what it
is
how many items are we gonna do like five
ten whatever you feel whatever you're
feeling jeff okay and if you
guess them all guess i'm all probably
was there like any
incentive like consequences well
do you want to make some i don't know do
you want money whenever you guess
incorrectly is mine love it
let me go get something we shook on it
we shook on it
wait no we didn't oh my gosh we verbally
agreed this is a contract
[Music]
why are you shaking my head she agreed
do
all right i think we got some things
i've got stuff in my pants
this this okay you have your head you're
you have your blindfold on
okay no peeking all right so we're back
we've got the items
uh we shook on it there's a verbal
agreement i think that if you didn't get
it then it's mine
i don't care if you can't guess it it's
coming over to
my house so you're gonna have to guess
if possible like the make the model the
year
oh like the type if you know what that
certain type of thing is
if it's gonna make sense it might make
sense okay first up
watch your watch those fingers oh
oh this is the oh i 100 i already know
what this is
this is the um it's the xbox
the uh don't look at me like i'm going
to tell you i can't even see it but
anyway
come on the gears 5. yeah definitely
because it has the
the like the frozen marks on it okay put
your hand out
i don't know this is the dji
osmo underwater
[Laughter]
yeah weird but like no i saw it and i'm
like what the heck is this
all right you're gonna be able to get
all of these you freak
all right next up remember you have to
you have to know as much information as
possible
through the razor no
not really now
you're lucky i'm not gonna want these
because they were probably in your slime
little ears
come on go back to the case so you know
what these are no it's too late
these are the air pods with the vintage
finish on them
they are but you are wrong i thought you
were trying to trick me
no okay next stop so i can't say
what it is i need to really focus on it
oh this is the apple uh floppy drive
from the 1984 mac that we unboxed
and you're lucky i also don't want that
but you were also correct
you're weird you're such i mean i feel
like maybe i should have given you a
more practical thing
all right next up on the list
sounds like a phone that you touched you
sound like a phone that i touched
oh you gave me something different oh
okay these are the
if you know the name of them you get a
bonus point
shoot i don't remember those those sony
headphones
if you know the name you get a bonus
point because i would always miss
that one letter i would always mix it up
with the actual headset compared to the
i'm not going to say the other one
because you got it kind of wrong come on
what are they called what are they
called you don't have to know because i
i always said no these were the the ones
that we got at that event
yeah i can't look at you with this nub
coming out of your head
i'll give you a hint the wf 1000
x blank blank
i don't remember what they're called
okay well they are the sony or the sony
the xm3
xn3 i don't remember that me either
that's why it was a tricky wait it's
like what are you doing
let's let what is this what do you think
like oh elon musk's second child's name
he changed it they changed they had to
legally because they couldn't put a
number so they made it a roman numeral
this is a good one this could be
potentially one of your
favorite pieces of tech ever to exist
you ready yes
oh my god for my label maker
you guys are loved okay i'm doing this
is that a handheld one
yeah i saw that i need a white boy in
the corner it's over there in the corner
i was like she's gonna know because
she's probably been looking at that one
forever
okay i'm not sure what i should give you
next
you don't actually know
[Music]
oh this is a challenge oh we may have
stopped the master
i couldn't tell what air pods were oh
yeah i know that's insane that's crazy
take a bite no don't do it actually
oh my gosh we have stumped her i can't
believe this is gonna be mine in ten
nine eight no seven times
six five four
three two one b
what is your final guess oh she can't
see the microphone
what black is those what is this
apparently the timer doesn't mean
anything
you have to guess we can't stay here all
day what if i gave you the color of it
yeah pink oh oh um is it the
um is it the ipod the shuffle
i think wow that was a long tricky one
yes i don't want
i'll tell you later how i figured that
out it's private we don't want to oh
it's probably me
later i'll tell you later okay next
device oh i forgot you couldn't see it
okay i already think i know what this is
this is the satellite phone
it's the the big garmin yes it is
how many times have you carried that
around and thankfully didn't need
it now i have two i know okay
uh it's the superdrive
yeah yeah i mean you know what that is
but you know what an ipod was
okay so hold on a second the airpods i
thought this was the trick
like why would you give me a set of air
pods when you know i wouldn't know that
ipod
ipod airpods you barely know
okay next
do i have to know the make and model
yeah you do and you should be able to
tell
i know it's a surface book or a surface
it's a surface
it's a surface it's a surface okay come
on
come on
well it's definitely a surface i don't
know which model you would not the
surface go
no it feels it's too big okay
is there anything that you could like
check to see like
a specific model would have i'm gonna be
here forever
what's your final guess i mean it's a
surface
what are you doing to me oh
[Music]
there we go i don't remember where this
was the surface pro x
okay you don't you don't you have a
point oh come on there you go
you just needed that like extra little
push you get like maybe half a point
oh wait is that yours then or is it half
yours yours
no i have one oh this is a heavy boy oh
okay i already know what this is
what happened to the back of it wait
actually i know this is
i know this is a macbook i think it
exploded
this is oh no it's the battery i don't
know
i don't actually have the ends yeah this
doesn't feel good it feels very very bad
do you have fire insurance oh i've given
her
don't get that weapon away from me
[Music]
that's a little one thing we're gonna
just move outside okay there's one more
put your little hands out sounds like a
pen
what is this oh oh it's the uh the first
iphone
[Music]
okay how many how many gigs eight
what's the model number i'll get that
okay we did a good that was fun are we
done
yeah i don't have anything else i didn't
think you were gonna get the dji
weird thing that one was so easy for me
i couldn't believe it
i didn't know if you ever handed me that
i'd be like what i don't know what this
is well jen thanks for making my video
this was really fun what so
what are you getting to take home with
you well today i'm taking home half of a
surface pro
x and a full thing of the uh retro air
pods
anyway thank you guys for watching go
check out jenna's channel she's also a
twitch streamer
oh god i mean i don't know if i am i
mean i might be i've been streaming on
twitch because i've been playing so many
video games something i should make this
like
work all right okay i'll see you guys
later literally stunning
oh i'm stuck you guys like my
flippers flippers slippers your flippers
look at these philippines look at this
stuff
isn't it neat wouldn't you think my
collection's complete
i've got gadgets and gizmos lensing
[Music]
you